La fin d'un mystère tout de suite sous vos yeux
Que se cache-t-il derrière ce tableau ?
Réponse A: Un truc pour jouer au morpion
Réponse B: Un portrait robot de Squeezie
Réponse C: Un zizi
Réponse D: Cyprien
Et maintenant fin des votes et sous vos yeux...
Voilà, ils pourront pas percer le mystère avant que je le perce moi-même
Les amis, avez-vous vu la vidéo récente de Seb qui s’appelle "Vous et moi" dans laquelle il parle de sa relation avec ses abonnés
Comment tout ce délire virtuel se retranscrit dans la vraie vie
à travers de vraies rencontres et des vrais moments,
parfois cools, parfois gênants, parfois étranges
Allez voir sa vidéo si vous l'avez pas fait parce qu'elle est vraiment marrante
Et je me suis reconnu dans 100% de ce qu'il a dit
Ça m'a donné une idée. Je me suis rappelé
Pas mal de rencontres que j'ai faites avec des abonnés, dans la vraie vie, avec vous
Mais, du coup, des rencontres pas du tout organisées
Pas des trucs dans des conventions
Pas des trucs où je sais que je vais faire des rencontres
Que tu sois avec des proches ou seul
Pressé, pas pressé
Dans 98% des cas, quand les gens viennent te voir
C'est bienveillant, c'est respectueux, c'est mignon !
Vraiment, c'est trop mignon !
Et moi j'essaie de renvoyer du gentil en face mais je vous connais pas donc je galère à trouver les mots
"Euh ... ouais ! Et toi ... euh, hum, tu vas ... tu vas être une super maman plus tard, je pense"
Je sais pas quoi dire comme compliments
Mais j'ai envie d'en dire puisque vous me complimentez et vous avez l'air tout gentil
Mais je sais rien de vous alors c'est très compliqué
Aujourd'hui, je vais pas vous parler de toutes ces rencontres positives, agréables, cools
Et qui représentent vraiment la majorité des fois où je vous vois
Je vais vous parler d'une minorité de rencontres qui m'ont traumatisé
Ça veut pas forcément dire que la personne en face était irrespectueuse ou quoi hein, pas du tout
Mais, le contexte ou la manière de faire de la personne, pour certains
Fait que j'ai eu un réel traumatisme, mais vraiment un réel traumatisme
Première situation:
Il est vrai, un jour dans ma vie j'ai eu une douleur
pendant plusieurs jours à ce qu'on appelle une énorme couille
Ça commence si bien
Et ! Ayant beaucoup trop traîné sur Internet
Et surtout les gens qui s'autoproclament médecins
Et qui te disent ce qu'ils pensent que tu as
Alors qu'ils t'ont pas du tout examiné
Ce qu'ils savent de ce que tu as c'est ton auto-examen à toi retranscrit à l'écrit d'une manière dégueulasse
Et la personne en face lit ton auto-examen dégueulasse et fait un diagnostic
Si vous avez un problème, vous avez mal quelque part, vous vous sentez pas bien, bla bla bla ...
Allez chez un médecin ! N'ouvrez pas Internet. C'est le début d'une grosse tourmente autrement
Bon moi à l'époque je savais pas ça, donc qu'est-ce que je fais: j'ouvre Internet en me disant
"Bon à tous les coups je vais lire que c'est un petit truc
Une petite torsion d'un canal des couilles qui va se remettre droit et on en parle plus"
Pas du tout ! Qu'est-ce que je lis ?
Je me souviens très bien
"Ta couille va atteindre 5 fois sa taille normale, et devenir rouge
Si tu n'agis pas dans les 2 heures, tu peux la perdre"
Quoi ?
Je vais perdre une couille, moi ?
Donc je prends au sérieux tout ça
Je commence à me mettre dans des états pas possibles etc...
Vous en faites pas, la personne abonnée arrive
Ça arrive, là vous vous dites qu'il y a pas de rapport mais il y a un rapport et il est immense
Du coup, j'appelle une clinique qui fait des échographies
Et je leur demande s'ils font des échographies testiculaires
C'est le nom scientifique de "l'échographie des couilles"
La personne me répond que "oui totalement c'est un truc qui se fait dans cette clinique
Et que, euh, je peux venir le lendemain à 13h", je crois
Bon bah cool, j'espère juste que ma couille ne va pas mourir dans la nuit
Le lendemain, je vais là-bas, je suis dans une salle d'attente où se trouvent d'autres hommes que je regarde
En me disant: "est-ce qu'ils vont aussi se faire une échographie testiculaire ou pas ?"
Parce qu'ils ont l'air dans un meilleur "mood" que moi
Désolé c'était la première fois que je devais montrer mes parties à un médecin pour des raisons médicales
Il y a aucune honte à ça. En vrai le médecin il s'en fout mais à un point ... mais colossal quoi
Et moi c'était ma première fois à moi qu'on me scannait une partie intime donc j'étais ... pas bien quoi !
Le médecin vient, je lui sers la main et je surveille son visage pour être sûr que
Le mec qui va me scanner la couille ce soit pas un abonné
Parce que c'est trop chelou quoi
C'est trop bizarre si c'est un abonné
Genre, il regarde mes vidéos, et tout, il aime bien machin
Et là il va me toucher une couille. Enfin, psychologiquement, c'est bizarre quoi
Je me sens pas bien
Vu son âge et comment il m'a regardé, etc..., je me dis que non c'est bon c'est pas un abonné
Tout va bien. Donc j'arrive dans cette salle sombre
Il me dit de me mettre les testicules à l'air finalement hein, ce que je fais
Et puis, il prend sa sonde là, il met du gel au bout et hop
Il la pose délicatement sur ma testicule
Et il fait son écho, ça dure un peu
Il finit et il me dit:
"Bon bah vous avez pas grand chose hein
Vous avez même rien en fait, vous devez avoir une petite torsion, dans la nuit vous avez dû mal vous mettre
Et ça a dû vous faire mal mais il y a vraiment rien quoi
Moi je vois rien, vous en faites pas, tout va bien
Là ! Je me sens héroïque, je me dis "putain j'ai traversé cette épreuve
En plus je n'ai rien, ma couille va bien, je vais la garder, je suis heureux !"
Et pendant que je suis dans mes pensées, le médecin me dit:
"Sinon j'aime bien vos vidéos hein, continuez !"
Attendez ... est-ce qu'un abonné vient de me scanner la couille ? ... maman ?
Il y en a qui peuvent croire qu'il m'a manqué de respect
Mais en vrai il a vu que j'étais en panique pendant tout le truc etc...
Donc il m'a rien de A à Z et à l'arrivée, c'était plus fort que lui il voulait me dire:
"J'aime bien ce que tu fais, continue !"
Et c'était pas méchant de sa part, c'était bienveillant mais moi ça m'a trauma quoi
Il y a quand même une personne, parmi vous, qui m'a touché la couille, voilà il faut le dire !
Et c'était pas un délire "Balance ton YouTubeur" ou quoi, non, non
C'était juste une échographie de la couille
Bref, ça m'a mis, mec, je suis rentré comme ça
Et j'ai regardé comme ça par la fenêtre pendant deux heures en me disant:
"Putain de merde, si je pensais un jour que ça m'arriverait dans ma vie !"
Bon ! Deuxième rencontre un peu chelou
J'étais un train de balader Natsu un matin, j'étais mal luné de ouf
Des fois je me réveille le matin, je suis mal luné comme tous les humains
Et je me dirige vers une marque qui vend des cafés à emporter
Article 13, on sait jamais !
Et là ! J'entends: "Squeeziiiiiiie !!"
Quoi ? Un mec m'a crié dessus, si fort, que je pense qu'il était à un kilomètre de moi
Il était à un kilomètre !
Et quand c'est comme ça, j'ai un peu peur de "l'effet zombie"
Genre que tous les gens tournent la tête vers moi etc...
Et j'aime pas du tout me faire remarquer dans la rue
Pas du tout parce que je suis une personnalité du net ou quoi, non
Juste parce que je veux pas me faire voir, je suis tranquille quoi
Bah vous savez, comme quand t'es dans un "mood" où t'es dans une espèce de solitude
Des fois pendant quelques heures et tu deviens une sorte d'animal quoi
Si on te touche tu fais: "Aaaah !" Tu peux mordre quoi carrément
"Bon bah je vais marcher et faire genre je l'ai pas entendu
Il est à un kilomètre, il va comprendre que je l'ai pas entendu
Deuxième cri: "Squeeziiiiiiiiiiiiiieeeeeee !!!"
Je me mets à marcher un peu vite, hop là ! On y va (x3)
Mais il était déterminé. Qu'est-ce que j'entends pendant que je fais cette marche athlétique ?
*bruit de pas stressants*
Le mec a fait un 150 mètres sprint
Et là le gars arrive à ma hauteur et je me dis:
"Ouais ça y est maintenant qu'il m'a atteint il va être cool et posé et il va peut-être même s'excuser d'avoir gueulé
grave plusieurs fois."
Pas du tout ! Il me frappe l'épaule. Il me frappe l'épaule !
Une tatane mon gars ! Même mon père il m'en a pas mis des comme ça
"Alors ! Tu m'entends pas ? Tu m'entends pas quand je crie ?"
Il a osé ! Il m'a hurlé dessus ! Même ma mère, quand je faisais du PC en cachette, ne m'hurlait pas dessus comme ça
Tu n'es pas ma maman ! Et tu cries plus fort qu'elle !
Et il s'était pas du tout rendu compte, à aucun moment, que c'est assez brusquant
Pour un être humain que quelqu'un t'hurle dessus à multiples reprises
Et que quand il arrive à ton niveau, il te frappe l'épaule
Et il m'a demandé une photo pour son fils ou je sais plus trop qui et ça m'a rendu ouf
Qu'on puisse autant ne pas se poser la question du: "est-ce que je suis en train de l'importuner ou pas ?"
Tu vois ? Et du coup je lui avais expliqué gentiment, je lui ai dit:
Mec, je suis vraiment désolé mais là, juste, tu viens d'hurler plein de fois "Squeezie" dans la rue
Ça m'a ultra gêné. Et quand t'arrives c'est pas genre tu m'abordes gentiment
C'est tu me mets un coup dans l'épaule, tu vois ? C'est pas cool. Donc, non, je ferai pas ta photo
Et la prochaine fois, repense à ton comportement quoi.
Je suis un humain. Tu peux pas me prendre pour un animal, tu vois ?
Et le gars il a vrillé. Et il s'est mis à m'insulter !
Il m'a regardé en mode: "Ah ouais ! Espèce d'enfoiré va ! Connard !"
Et c'est ça qui m'a trauma quoi.
C'est que le gars il a vrillé d'un coup et il m'a insulté, genre il faisait un scandale devant tout le monde
Alors que, juste, je venais de me faire crier dessus.
Alors que j'avais rien demandé. Je promenais mon chien tranquillement.
S'il avait fait une démarche respectueuse et bienveillante, il y aurait eu aucun souci.
Mais là mec, c'était si agressif !
J'entends encore ses "Squeeziiiiiiiiiieee !!!"
Aaah j'ai peur !
Je vous jure que quand quelqu'un vous crie dessus comme ça en public
Aussi fort, qu'il vous court après et qu'il y a tous les gens
qui vous regardent parce qu'ils comprennent pas ce qu'il se passe
Bah t'as pas envie de donner à la personne ce qu'elle voulait parce que c'est lui donner raison
D'avoir eu un tel comportement, je trouve.
Et il y a plein de fois où j'ai laissé passer de ouf des trucs comme ça
Et cette fois-là, je me suis dit: "Non ! Là c'est trop ! C'est n'importe quoi ! Je suis pas un animal quoi. C'est n'importe quoi."
C'était vraiment choquant mec. Je me suis fait crier dessus et insulter par un inconnu dans la rue.
J'ai passé une bonne journée derrière.
Et j'en viens donc à la troisième anecdote:
Un jour j'étais au Japon, en vacances, tranquillement
Et je me baladais dans un quartier à Tokyo
Et j'ai vu qu'il y avait un petit groupe de français qui m'avaient reconnu
Mais ils avaient le comportement de ceux qui t'ont reconnu, qui osent pas venir
Te taper sur l'épaule pour que tu te retournes et qui, du coup, restent à une certaine distance et qui te suivent
Pendant plus ou moins longtemps, en faisant  "Squeezie" de temps en temps
Mais ils l'ont fait pendant super longtemps genre pendant 25 minutes, tu vois.
Je marchais et ça faisait "Squeezie"
Et comme j'étais au Japon en mode vacances, gros break avec YouTube, etc..., Internet et tout
Ça me ramenait à mon quotidien et ça me rendait un peu ouf quoi.
J'étais en mode: "non ... laissez moi !"
J'étais un ogre, un ogre.
Et en fait, je prends une rue à gauche pour aller dans une boutique
Et le mec se détache de son groupe, prend la rue, me suit et puis il me tape sur l'épaule
Et je me retourne, et je m'en veux encore, mais vous allez voir la suite ça finit bien.
Je lui ai tellement mal parlé. J'ai vraiment été un gros con et je m'en suis voulu.
"Euh mec, déjà tu cries mon nom depuis je sais pas combien de temps. C'est bon je t'ai entendu."
Et ensuite, là je suis en vacances. Je fais pas de photos, je fais rien. Désolé, bonne journée."
Ouais, je me déplaçais en chaise de bureau à Tokyo.
Et en me retournant, pendant que je lui ai dit ce discours de connard, j'ai vu son visage au gars.
Un visage mignon, heureux, vraiment de gars gentil
Qui voulait vraiment pas déranger mais qui a pas pu s'empêcher de venir me voir
Parce qu'il sait que ça se reproduira pas et qu'il voulait me dire quelque chose.
Et je sais pas, pendant 5 minutes, j'y pensais comme ça dans le magasin et je me dis:
"C'est pas possible, il faut que j'y retourne. C'est trop injuste ce que je lui ai mis dans la tête.
C'est parfaitement injuste. Il faut que j'aille le voir pour m'excuser."
Et donc je pars en courant du magasin, je cours comme ça dans la rue.
Je le cherche. Je regarde à gauche et à droite, je le vois pas.
Et je cours, je cours, je cours. Et au final je finis par l'apercevoir, il avait rejoint son groupe de potes.
Et je lui dis: "Re, je suis vraiment désolé de ce que je t'ai dit et tout. C'était vraiment pas sympa de ma part.
Vraiment je m'excuse et tout."
Et le mec me regarde et me dit:
"Ah mais il y a pas de souci. T'es en vacances, je comprends. Il y a aucun problème. T'inquiète.
Je suis vraiment désolé de t'avoir dérangé et tout."
Et là j'avais envie de pleurer tellement il était gentil quoi.
Gentil et trop bienveillant.
Le mec, je lui avais ultra mal parlé et il l'a tellement pas mal pris
Et il était tellement en mode: "Ouais c'est pas grave, il est occupé. Il est en vacances avec sa meuf.
Je comprends et tout."
Tellement gentil ! Et j'étais tellement content d'être retourné le voir qu'on a parlé pendant 15 minutes
Avec lui et ses potes. C'était un expatrié et ses potes l'avaient rejoint au Japon
Et du coup ils se faisaient une petite semaine entre potes là-bas et c'était vraiment cool
Comme moment, comme discussion et tout donc merci à toi si tu regardes cette vidéo et désolé !
Ça montre que, des fois, les gens qui t'accostent peuvent mal s'y prendre
Mais nous aussi dans notre réponse, des fois, on peut encore plus mal s'y prendre quoi
Bon voilà, ça m'a marqué. C'était il y a deux ans et j'y pense encore régulièrement
Et à chaque fois, je pense à ça et je me dis:
"Peu importe la personne qui vient te voir, c'est pas méchant, tu vois."
Ils sont juste touchés de te voir en vrai et même si ça te dérange parfois
Parce que t'es pressé ou t'es dans un vieux "mood", etc...
Il faut pas les traiter comme ce jour-là j'ai traité ce gars-là
Ça a été une vraie leçon pour moi donc merci à toi !
Bon ! Une fois, il m'est arrivé quelque chose d'horrible, il y a 4 ans
Euh mon adresse avait fuité sur Internet
Voilà, c'est la pire chose qui puisse t'arriver
Tout simplement pour un YouTubeur, c'est horrible parce qu'il y a pas mal de gens parmi vous
Qui ont du mal à concevoir ça mais il y a vraiment des gens qui viennent, qui sonnent, qui re-sonnent
Qui re-sonnent, qui, finalement, harcèlent, en fait
Ici, je suis au studio, je suis au bureau. Je suis dans le cadre professionnel. Donc je m'en fous un peu.
Mais dans la vie privée, c'est chaud quand même.
Quand t'as des groupes de gens qui sonnent chez toi en boucle, etc...
C'est pas amusant.
Et en fait, ça m'était arrivé à Arcueil-Cachan, à l'époque j'y habitais.
Mon adresse avait pas fuité sur le net mais il y avait une université où les gens savaient que j'habitais là.
Mais c'était quand même un immeuble, il y avait le digicode, etc... Ils sonnaient à l'interphone, bon ça allait.
Mais après j'ai déménagé. Je suis allé dans une maison à l'Haÿ-les-Roses
Et une maison où il y avait pas de portail. T'avais accès à la porte d'entrée de la maison comme ça
C'était côté rue, il y avait pas de portail ni rien, pas de protection quoi.
Et en fait, quand je rentrais, tous les jours, il y avait des jeunes devant la maison
Donc je leur disais:
"Bah, les amis, c'est la vie privée là. Vous attendez devant chez moi, c'est un peu limite quoi.
Mais le pire c'est que des fois
J'étais dans le salon. Je regardais du Netflix ou je sais pas quoi.
Et il y avait les fenêtres à droite comme ça.
Et je regardais à droite et je voyais des gens qui avaient leur visage collé comme ça
Qui regardaient chez moi comme ça.
Et je les regardais et je pouvais rien faire.
J'étais en mode: "Putain, c'est ça ma vie."
C'est avoir des petits lutins comme ça aux fenêtres qui font: "Hiiii !"
Et je sais que c'est trop pas méchant de la part de ces personnes-là. Elles savent pas du tout que ça fait du mal
Et que ça te met ... que ça te fout la haine quoi.
Elles savent pas du tout. Elles se doutent pas.
Souvent c'est des gens assez jeunes qui font ça, c'est pas du tout des gens qui ont mon âge ou quoi
C'est des gens, où moi aussi à leur âge j'avais pas conscience qu'en faisant ça, ça importune
la personne que tu regardes en fait.
Et donc, ça a été ça pendant de nombreux mois.
Un big-up à tous ces gens qui m'ont vu en slip sur mon canapé, qui sont venus voir à ma fenêtre.
J'espère, au moins, que vous, vous passiez un bon moment.
J'espère que le spectacle était à la hauteur de vos attentes.
Et dernière chose !
Une rencontre, il y a pas longtemps, que j'ai faite.
Il y aussi des gens qui sont ultra mignons.
Ils viennent et ils veulent absolument pas te déranger.
Même si tu leur dis: "Non mais tu me déranges pas."
Ils vont te dire: "Si, si je te dérange, je le vois bien. Au revoir. T'inquiète, je t'aime, au revoir."
Et c'est trop mignon de leur part et en fait ils t'aiment tellement
Qu'ils veulent pas prendre le mini risque de t'importuner
Parce que ça les ferait chier
Je trouve ça tellement, tellement adorable !
Et ce matin encore au moment où je tourne cette vidéo
Un gars, que je vais appeler M. Super Dry parce qu'il avait un sac à dos Super Dry,
C'est tout ce dont je me souviens. Gros big-up à toi, bisous si tu regardes cette vidéo.
Et il est venu et il me dit:
"Je veux pas t'importuner mais merci pour tes vidéos, elles m'ont aidé dans un moment de ma vie où j'étais
pas très bien. Elles m'ont vraiment fait du bien. Depuis j'ai remonté la pente. Mais voilà je voulais te
remercier pour ce que tu as fait pour moi et bonne continuation !"
Et il se barre comme ça
Et moi j'avais envie de lui parler:
"M. Super Dry, attendez ! Vous êtes vraiment sympathique !"
Et lui il partait, quoiqu'il arrive.
Comme s'il était mort et que son âme était restée sur terre
et qu'il avait besoin de me dire ça avant de s'envoler au paradis, tu vois.
C'est vraiment ce que j'ai ressenti.
J'aurais pu crier, faire ce que je voulais, non il partait. Il a dit ce qu'il avait à dire. Il part la tête haute
Et heureux de ce moment très court mais très intense.
Donc voilà, n'hésitez pas à faire un gros big-up à M. Super Dry dans les commentaires, ça lui fera plaisir.
Il était adorable.
C'est la fin de ces péripéties qui sortaient du commun.
Il y a eu plein d'autres rencontres où il y avait pas des trucs comme ça
Qui étaient beaucoup plus tranquilles, normales et cools.
Mais là, c'est vraiment celles qui m'ont marqué.
En tout cas, si vous croisez un YouTubeur, ou un chanteur ou un acteur, je sais pas, que vous adorez
Et que vous voulez aller le voir
Faites-le toujours dans une démarche respectueuse
C'est-à-dire s'il est en famille ou avec sa meuf
Vous savez que c'est un moment où il est en train de kiffer avec des gens
Et que du coup vous coupez ce moment-là si vous allez le voir
Criez pas son nom !
Allez le voir tranquillement, discrètement
Hop ! Et je vous jure que là il y a aucun problème.
Et parfois, même moi, comme je vous disais, quand je suis à la boulangerie ou en train de sortir Natsu et tout
Ça me dérange pas de vous parler pendant un petit moment mais parfois quand je suis pas "disponible"
Bah je vais écourter le truc, je vais être moins dedans quoi, mais il faut pas m'en vouloir
C'est juste qu'il y a des moments "pour", des moments qui sont moins "pour"
Et dans tous les cas c'est cool mais parfois ça peut être plus court que d'autres moments
Voilà, je sais pas si je suis très clair.
À bientôt tout le monde, au revoir !
Eh mais ! Eh mais c'est Seb là-bas !
Seeeeeb ! Eh Seb ! Eh t'es le YouTubeur non ? Seeeb !